[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Jean Ross vice
president of evangelism for amazing
facts hello friends how about an amazing
fact born on June 15 1959 Michel Lotito
was a Frenchman with a very unusual diet
at the age of 9 he began eating large
quantities of metal and glass in later
life if we came and entertain and took
the nickname mr. eat all things and it
seemed that his body was able to live up
to his unusual nickname he was known to
have eaten supermarket carts television
sets bicycles chandeliers razor blades
bullets nuts and bolts length of chain
computers and an entire Cessna 150
aircraft which took him nearly two years
to consume his technique included
lubricating his digestive tract with
mineral oil cutting the parts into
bite-sized pieces and then consuming a
large quantity of water while eating the
junk what his most amazing is that it
didn't seem to suffer any unusual side
effects from eating materials usually
considered poisonous it is believed that
between 1959 and 1997 he consumed about
one ton of metal he said as a child he
liked the taste of metal and wanted to
impress his friends by eating metal
objects he then discovered that he could
win bets by eating things like nails and
glass plates over time he developed a
technique that allowed him to eat almost
anything
Michel died of natural causes On June 25
2007 ten days before his 57th birthday
friends did you know that the Bible
encourages us to eat
something that is not food every day
while stay tuned for more as amazing
facts brings you this edition of Bible
answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
one eight hundred four sixty three
seventy to ninety seven now let's join
our host pastors John Ross hello friends
this is Bible answers live pastor Doug
batchly is out this evening but the
phone lines are open and we're ready to
take your Bible calls if you have a
Bible related question the phone number
to call again is 800 four six three
seven two nine seven that number once
again is 800 four six three seven two
nine seven that'll bring you right here
into the studio with your Bible related
Christian maybe you have questions about
the Word of God maybe about a particular
text that's puzzled you or just general
questions about living the Christian
life well this is a good time to pick up
your phone and give us a call our phone
lines are now open that number once
again it's eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven or if you can
remember it this way it's eight hundred
God says 804 63 72 97 now open the
program with an amazing fact about a
gentleman who well made a living at
eating all kinds of strange things I
mean things that you'd never consider
food and yet somehow he seemed to
survive he had figured out this
technique of being able to eat metal and
glass and it just passed right through
your system you know the Bible speaks
about the Christian needing to eat
something every day that's not food now
of course I'm not talking about eating
glass or metal or something strange like
that I'm talking about eating something
spiritual in the book of Revelation you
read about John envisioned being told by
an angel to take a book and eat the book
it said that the book would be sweet in
his mouth but bitter in his stomach and
John does just that and that's exactly
what happens what does it mean to eat
the book well Jeremiah chapter 15 verse
16 says thy words were found and I did
eat them
and they weren't me the joy and the
rejoicing of my heart
so to eat the book at least in spiritual
terms is to receive it and make it your
own you see every day we need a feast
upon the Word of God and to eat the word
is to receive it to make it your own to
allow the spirit of God's Word to
transform our lives jesus said this in
John chapter 6 verse 53 speaking to his
disciples and many others at a large
crowd that followed him he said most
assuredly I say unto you unless you eat
the flesh of the Son of Man and drink
his blood you have no life in you they
could imagine this caused a lot of
questions in the minds of the hearers of
Jesus what does it mean to eat his flesh
and drink his blood there were many who
actually offended by this and they left
finally Jesus was there with these
disciples and he said to them are you
also gonna leave me and they said Lord
or where are we to go you have the words
of truth but this was a hard saying what
does it mean to eat your flesh and drink
your blood Jesus then explains in John
chapter 6 verse 63 he said it is the
spirit that gives life the flesh profits
nothing the words I speak to you their
spirit and their life so to eat the
flesh and to drink the blood of Christ
is to receive his word to receive his
teaching to make it a part of your very
life so yes friends there is something
that we need to eat every single day for
spiritual health even more important
than physical food that's the Word of
God and that's actually what our free
offer is about tonight it is a book
dealing with the Bible called the
ultimate resource and we want to send
this to anybody who calls and asks this
is our resource phone line if you have a
pencil hope you're ready here it is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven that's 800 eight three five
six seven four seven and you can ask for
the book called the ultimate resource
it's all about the Bible how you can
study the Bible how you can learn to
receive the blessing of the scriptures
just call and we'll be happy to send
that to you once again that number is
885 six seven four seven and if you have
a Bible question a phone line here to
the studio is 800
four six three seven two nine seven I
can see this phone calls coming in right
now if you don't get through right away
just hold on we'll get to your call
again that number is eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven well
before we go to the phone lines always
like to begin the program with the word
of Prayer we recognize the Bible is
God's book and we need the Holy Spirit
in order to understand it so let's pray
together dear father we thank you for
this opportunity for us to open up your
word and study together we want to ask
the Holy Spirit to come and guard our
hearts and our minds lead us into a
clearer understanding of what the Bible
teaches so that we can indeed feast upon
the Living bread that is the word thank
you Lord for hearing our prayer in Jesus
name Amen
well we really go to the phone lines
with our first caller this evening we
have let's see we have Richmond or I'll
calling from Richmond Indiana hi Rio
welcome to the program yeah good evening
pastor Roz thank you for your ministry
and for taking my call well thanks for
come
yeah my question is in judges 19 we have
the story of the Levite and his
concubine concubine is unfaithful left
the Levite and returned to her father's
place and then the Levite loser back but
then on the way home allows her to be
raped and murdered basically by the men
of Gibeah but then he ends up cutting
her corpse up into 12 pieces and sending
it to Israel so I've heard people say
that the story is included in the Bible
because it just shows how bad people can
get when there's no law or when they
don't follow God but does this have a
spiritual significance like there's a
woman represent the church or I mean
then that the Levites represent God it
doesn't sound like yeah well that's the
Gauley trait sure you know definitely
it's a it's a difficult story it was
during the time when there was no king
pretty much regions of Israel were
governed by different judges and the
Bible describes that time as a time
period when every man did what that
which was right in his own eyes
and it's a sad story you have this
Levite who has a wife concubine but she
leaves him goes back to a father's house
and it appears as though she played the
role of a prostitute or harlot and he
finally went after her and he wooed her
back and they were actually journeying
on their way back to the mountain areas
where he was from and he stopped in the
city spent the night there and the
wicked men of the city came up against
the house the owner of the house or was
threatening to kill him
and it's kind of sad but yes the Levite
and
the man gave them his concubine now
perhaps the rationale behind that was
because of her reputation because of
what she had just recently be doing
perhaps they considered that you know
something would happen but they didn't
think that it would cost her her life
and in the morning when that did happen
and she died because of the wickedness
of these men to kind of display the
terrible son of Israel her body was
divided up into twelve parts and the
Levite sent it to the twelve tribes
which caused a civil war in Israel and
they fought against Benjamin a Gibeon
was one of the cities there in Benjamin
and almost completely destroyed the
tribe of Benjamin so the reason it's
mentioned in Scripture is because of its
impact on the nation of Israel and the
different tribes is their spiritual
significance you know to some degree I
think there are some broad principles
that we see in Scripture in the Bible
sometimes a woman can represent a church
in Old Testament times Israel is
sometimes described as a harlot woman
who is like like no more yes there was
supposed to be devoted to God but left
their allegiance to God and followed the
customs and the idols and the forms of
worship of the pagan nations around her
and you know eventually judgment came
upon Israel when you had the Assyrians
conquered the ten tribes of the north
and Babylon conquered Jerusalem and a
little bit of Benjamin that was left so
perhaps there's something there some
lessons that we can learn but I think
the prime reason why this is mentioned
in Scripture is because it connects the
his
tree of Israel God's people and what the
condition was at that time in Israel
because I I don't hear any sermons on it
you know yeah you know it's kind of a
difficult passage to deal with because
it is kind of sad it's it's a terrible
discrete numb of what had happened yes
and gruesome what had happened in Israel
when they left their allegiance to God
okay all right well thanks for your call
good question our next caller this
evening is Gabino listening in San
Antonio Texas Camino welcome to the
program thank you sir
he thinks you're home I've read the
Bible with a hopeful and I'm reading it
again and as more as I read him more and
more I began to digest and I began to
understand but there are certain places
where I do not understand for example
revelation 12:7 where says there was war
in heaven Michael and his angels fought
against the dragon his angels and they
were forced out of heaven and they were
cast down to the earth mm-hmm why why
would they why were they cast down
through the years okay well that's a
good question the passage of course that
you referring to these Revelation
chapter 12 starting in verse 7 you know
after this rebellion took place in
heaven and the reason we have this
rebellion is because the most leading
angel in heaven his name was Lucifer
coveted God's position and wanted the
worship of the other angels and
eventually this resulted in full-blown
rebellion against God and against his
government finally he was driven out of
heaven he and his angels he was able to
deceive at least a third of the angels
to join his rebellion against God and
probably for a time period the devil
sort of went from place to place in the
universe looking for some place that he
could establish his kingdom in
opposition to God's kingdom right around
this time the earth is created and
because on the earth God creates a
beautiful garden Adam and Eve he's
placed in the garden God warns them and
says you can eat of all the trees of the
garden but don't eat of the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil
limited satan's access to Adam and Eve
to that one tree but you know the story
how that you know they disobeyed God ate
of the forbidden fruit and sin came into
the world now when God created the earth
and he created Adam he gave Adam
dominion over this world he was to be
the representative of the earth but when
Adam disobeyed God and chose Satan
instead of God in essence he handed his
dominion over to Satan and Satan claimed
this earth as his and so this earth then
became sort of the capital of the
devil's Kingdom and his opposition
against God it was not that God forced
the devil on the earth rather it was the
freedom of choice that God had given to
Adam and Eve in choosing the devil's way
they chose the devil instead of God that
Satan claimed the earth as his okay and
then of course after that he was cast to
the earth meaning that you know this is
where he's limited you reading the book
of Job how that there was a meeting
probably in heaven and Satan came as the
representative of earth and God said
well if you come from he said from
walking up and down on the earth from
walking up and down and his kingdom in
essence and God said have you considered
my servant job in other words God said
there is someone in your kingdom then
actually belongs in my kingdom
hang hear the whole story about about
joke but when Jesus died on the cross he
became the second Adam he took the place
of the first Adam and now the kingdom
the earth is really Christ's and of
course the kingdom becomes his fully
when Jesus comes the second time so the
devil's days are numbered so so you say
when when God created the earth the
devil was only testing other planets
you know quite possibly I mean the Bible
speaks of in job talks about these
representatives of unfallen worlds
refers to them as elders there in heaven
and we also read about the 24 elders in
the book of Revelation they could very
well have been the representatives of
other worlds you know the Bible speaks
of Christ creating the world's uses the
word plural so there could be other
out there that didn't fall that remained
loyal to God and it was our earth that
fell and that's why Satan claims this
earth as his kingdom okay thank you sir
appreciate it
all right great question if you have a
Bible question our phone line here to
the studio is eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven that is 804
63 72 97 anacs holy is Pam listening
Billings Montana Pam welcome to the
program oh thank you very much it's an
honor to speak to you Pastor Bob well
thanks for calling you bet I have a
question I I know you guys have have had
many questions about this chapter and
parable I've read the Bible for years
and I still don't quite grasp it's
Matthew chapter 22 particularly verses
10 through 14 and about the you know the
man that shows up you know he was bid to
the the wedding and he came and then
when the King saw it yes and he had not
on a wedding garment and he's cast out
and and I never I never that always
disturbs me I never quite understand the
meaning of the parable
okay sure good question it's a great
parable as you said you find a Matthew
chapter 22 for those who might be
driving let me just summarize what this
parable is and then we can talk about
its meaning it's it's very significant
the parable get begins by Jesus saying
the kingdom of heaven is likened to a
certain king who arranged a marriage for
his son so if Jesus beginning a parable
he's talking about a king and the king
has a son and the son is about to get
married you know it represents something
the king would represent God the Father
the Son would represent his son and the
marriage would represent Christ
reception of his bride the church Christ
reception of his kingdom and then it
says the king arranged everything needed
for this wedding and it talks about how
he had prepared the meal talks about my
oxen my fatted cattle are killed all
things already come to the wedding and
then those who were first invited to
come to the wedding they didn't want to
come every time they were
vided they made an excuse and the one
said you know I can come because of this
and another said I have a farm that I
need to take care of or business some of
those were invited took the servants of
the king and killed them and treated
them badly then it says but the King
heard about this he was angry and he
sent out his armies who destroyed those
murderers burnt up this city those are
the ones who were first invited then he
said these servants the wedding is ready
but those who were invited or not worthy
go therefore into the highways and as
many as you find invite them to the
wedding so the servants went out into
the highways and the byways named vited
all these people to come and the wedding
hall was furnished with guests everybody
was there seated waiting for the wedding
to about to take place then it says the
king came in and he was examining all
looking at the guests and he saw a man
that was sitting there in the wedding
hall that didn't have on a wedding
garment and the king said how did you
come in here without the wedding garment
the man was speechless and then you had
those verses in particular that you're
talking about where the King says bind
him hand and foot and throw him outside
now of course in the parable we spoke
about who the King represents represents
the father the son represents Jesus the
marriage represents Christ reception of
his bride and Kingdom those who were
first invited represents the Jewish
nation as a whole when it says that they
took the servants and they treated them
spitefully and even killed him it's
referring to how the prophets would come
and they would preach to those in Israel
and they would treat it very badly some
of them we even put to death and then it
says the city eventually was destroyed
well that happened in 70 AD when the
Romans came and destroyed Jerusalem but
then the King said everything is ready
for the wedding in other words Christ
had already died the sacrifice had being
provided and then going to the highways
and the byways and invite as many as you
can that refers to the gospel now going
out at the Gentile world not only just
for the Jews but for anyone and everyone
to every nation kindred tongue and
people and then there were many who
responded to the gospel invitation then
it talks about everybody gathered in the
hall the wedding hall just before the
marriage is to take place and there is a
man I didn't have on the wedding garment
you see just before
as comes that's when Jesus comes the
second time that you have the wedding
that takes place because it talks about
the marriage supper of the Lamb that
occurs in heaven after the second coming
but just before Jesus comes there is an
examination of those who claim to be
Christians it is examining the guests
there are many who claim to be
Christians but they don't have on or if
not they have not by faith received the
righteousness of Jesus so they are
sitting there in their own filthy
garments before Jesus comes there is a
judgment or an examining of those who
profess to be Christians those who have
found to simply be Christian in name but
have not committed themselves to Christ
they cast out but they won't be ready
when Jesus comes the second time so
that's really what this parable is
referencing it's talking about a special
time that happens just before Jesus
comes I believe we living in that time
now where there is to some degree in
examining of those who profess to be
followers of Christ oh wow there's a lot
in that parable I know we just slip
right through it but read it again with
that in mind and I think it'll make
sense no I
I truly appreciate that because I like I
said I've read that for years and years
and and you know I
I've been a Christian for many years and
it just did the the explanations has
never quite understood know that and I
get it thank you good thanks to a cold
man we appreciate it
I next call he is at Thomas listening
from a Long Island Thomas welcome to
Bible answers live yeah good evening
pastor how are you doing doing well
thank it's calling okay sir then my
question is after Mary gave it birth to
Jesus she heard the children also you
know the other children that she she had
or could have had it's not clear there
were other brothers and sisters that
Jesus had but they were probably half
siblings from Joseph prior to his
marriage we know wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait can we give me
a passion to support what what decade
what you saying yes the day Bible is a
crystal clear it says she had four four
four four children and daughters four
sons and daughters right I know we're
doing where the four epistles out and
then James James in Greek it means
iakovos are know how this name can
involve with a James I don't I have no
clue that sure well let me explain about
that clear it does say that Jesus did
have brothers and sisters but like it
appears from the context and I'll
explain why in just a minute that they
were probably the half siblings of
Christ
Joseph was most likely married of course
he died a lot earlier been Mary and
these other siblings appeared older than
Jesus because they wanted to tell Jesus
what to do you'll remember a story where
Jesus was with the disciples and Mary
came and his half brothers and sisters
and they wanted to tell Jesus what he
was to do with reference to his ministry
and Jesus turned to the crowd when sort
of what it read that what chapter well
I'd have to look that up maybe you can
help me if you got your Bible in front
of me isn't there is no way there is no
passage to say to support that number
two when they want to register in Egypt
said Joseph and Mary does not if you
know like what what you saying that
Joseph was divorced had a children from
previously Mary okay that's not the
Bible support that number three from the
the Shepherd's went to this to the to
see Jesus when he was born in the stable
the fun Mary and Jesus does not mention
anywhere in the Bible that was other
children too okay well let me give you a
few verses on that st. you're asking if
you look in mark chapter three and you
start reading verse in 31 it says then
the brothers and his mother came
standing outside they sent him calling
him so this is talking about Jesus and
the multitude was sitting around him and
they said him look your mother and your
brothers
our outside seeking you but he answered
and said who is my mother or my brothers
and he looked around in a circle at
those who sat by him and said here are
my mother and my brothers forever does
the will of my father he is my brother
and my sister so there it does say the
Jesus did her brothers okay you know why
he said that why you know why this did
say that he say that because here the
one-play dissolved anybody
those who do my will these are my
brothers in my sisters if you got waxed
ax number one also to support to
advocate what I'm saying you will see
everybody down and all the disciples
Mary and the brothers in everybody else
so the Bible say crystal clear there is
no way in the Bible to support that
according to the Greek priest and the
Catholic mythology the other science
exactly sometimes our wars around that
will make our own theology I know I
understand you guys you know you preach
very well but this is well that it's a
it's a false all right well you know
everybody is from Greece I know the
language very well so as far as that you
know I miss every all the way so there
is no evidence that Mary I mean George
Escada the children for previously
married because I can't tell you yeah
well you know my yeah well you know what
I appreciate you sharing with us all
I'll have to go with is what the Bible
says they are brothers and it appears
that his mother came the question is did
Mary have other children it doesn't
appear that way because when Jesus was
on the cross he gave Mary into the
guardianship of John one of his
disciples if Christ if Mary would have
had other children or other sons it
would have been their responsibility to
take care of her so that's why a number
of scholars feel that these brothers of
Christ were actually the sons of Joseph
from his first marriage and his first
wife died and then he married Mary so
anyway I appreciate your call but that's
kind of what you we see here in these
passages of Scripture let's see our next
caller I think we have time for one more
before the break we have Raymond
listening from
Michigan Raymond welcome to the program
we have about a minute okay how can I
ask a question about Adam and Eve and
good that's good and evil but I guess
you you're one caller cars and and ass
answered my question oh well good and
there you go we've got two for the price
of one that was there was good did you
have another question you wanted to ask
or did you want to expand on that one or
oh you know what Raymond I hear I hear
some music playing in the background if
you hold on until after the break we'll
take your call that'll give you a chance
to kind of think about what you'd like
to ask so don't go away we're just got a
few announcements
we have stations identify themselves and
then we'll be right back with more Bible
answers if you have a Bible question get
ready I'll be giving you the phone line
number just after the break and we'd
love to hear from you if you have a
Bible related question we'll be right
back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this 95
minute masterpiece brings to life the
book of Revelation like never before
revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore calm
in six days God created the heavens and
the earth for thousands of years man has
worshiped God on the seventh day of the
week now each week millions of people
worship on the first day what happened
why did God create a day of rest does it
really matter what day we worship who is
behind this great shift discover the
truth behind God's law and how it was
changed visit Sabbath truth com can't
get enough amazing facts Bible study you
don't have to wait until next week to
enjoy more truth filled programming
visit the amazing facts media library at
aft vor G at aft vor G you can enjoy
video and audio presentations as well as
printed material all free of charge 24
hours a day seven days a week right from
your computer or mobile device visit aft
vor G every Bible question you have
answered moves you one step closer to
the fullness of God's will for your life
so what are you waiting for get the
answers you need
for a fuller richer more confident life
you're listening to Bible answers live
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this evening's program call
hello friends yes this is Bible answers
live a live international interactive
Bible study and if you have a Bible
related question we would love to hear
from you tonight
a phone line here to the student looks
like we got three lines still open is
800 four six three seven two nine seven
that number again is 800 four six three
seven two nine seven if you have a
question about a particular passage of
scripture just Christian in general
relating to the Christian life this is a
good time to pick up your phone and give
us a call not just before the break we
were talking to Raymond from Michigan
Raymond are you still there yes all
right thanks for your patience you had
said you had a question related to Adam
and Eve in the fall I did like I said so
you were the one callers calling and III
would answer that but I've another
question truck it's in the beginning you
know before God the triggers he was
always there God the Father God the Son
God the Holy Spirit before any and
everything was created they created the
Angels first and then there's everything
else that true that how I was you know
it appears that way that you know God
the Father the Son and the Holy Spirit
they have no end and for us to try and
figure out how that could be it's
something beyond human comprehension I
mean we live in a dimension of time our
lives revolve around time you know we
have birth that we have death and
everything in between but for God he is
outside of our time he is no beginning
no end
we know the angels were created by him
as well as all things in the universe it
appears as though the angels are created
or were created earlier definitely
earlier than Earth we know that with
reference to the rest of the universe
that's something the Bible doesn't tell
us for sure but they've been around for
a long time yeah and just before the
before they
created the human race and also Lucifer
and the one-third that fell with him did
they know did they know or today
did they know that Jesus would have to
die on the cross for the sins of the
earth sins of the human race you know I
think the whole plan of redemption and
the fact that Jesus came wasn't
unfolding even to the disciple or rather
even to the Angels I should say it was
an unfolding of God's great love and his
willingness to save even at an
incredible cost to himself they didn't
fully understand it but they probably
you know had some idea with the
introduction of the sacrificial system
that occurred after Adam and Eve sinned
sacrificing a lamb and then that
pointing forward to the Lamb of God who
would take away the sins of the world
but they learned through this whole
experience a new revelation of God's
love in saving mankind
well thanks you a : appreciate it and
God bless next caller that we have is
her a listening from New York all right
welcome to the program thank you yes I
have a question about the Old Testament
all my life I read in the Old Testament
that our patriarchs you know people used
to live over 400 years
like Methuselah 969 because also in the
Sun it refers to man lifespan to be 70
yes was very healthy he will live a
little bit longer correct but it was a
big difference between people living 400
years and being in the Sun it says mine
to live only 70 years right so I always
wonder if he's a big difference between
years in the Old Testament and the
later on okay well let me answer that
that's a good question no the years have
always been the same and the reason
being is you know when it talks about
creation it says that God created the
earth in six days it rested on the
seventh day a day consists of 24 hours
and you have you know the earth moving
around the Sun which would give you a
year the reason the people living before
the flood lived so long you have
Methuselah lived 969 years there are
others even up to the 800s and 900s
the world before the flood the
environment before the flood was very
different you know we know that we can
go back in the archaeological record and
we could see that a lot of the plants
and the animals that lived before the
flood were a much larger in size the
atmosphere was probably different before
the flood there was lush vegetation they
were not as many diseases and it wasn't
until after the flood that you begin to
see the age of people begin to get less
and less until it's settled down
somewhere around about 70 and then even
in modern times you know three four five
hundred years ago if you want to call
that modern times the life expectancy
was even less typically around 50 if you
were lucky maybe the 60 because the
diseases that were present and the type
of food that people were eating now life
expectancy is beginning to get a little
bit better
because we are generally trying to eat
healthy healthier and environments are
changing so the reason we have those
those long ages of those who live before
the flood
the main reason would have been because
the environment was so much different
than what it is today because I always
questioned the difference but now you
made it clear for me I appreciate it
thank you very much all right thank you
for your call if you have a Bible
related question the phone line here the
studio is eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven with your Bible
question that's 800 463 seven 297 I'd
love to hear from you this evening our
next caller is Tommy listening in
Orlando tell me
welcome to the program hello pastor John
and thank you for taking my call
you're welcome so my question and I'm
really not sure how to phrase it but the
dead in Christ in those who are still
alive in Christ when he returns a
understanding that we will receive our
new bodies at that time and we'll go
back to heaven with Jesus to live and
then at some point come back to the
earth to reign on earth and then the
wicked will be raised again is this
correct yes yep you right there let me
run through the sequence we have the
second coming of Jesus the dead in
Christ are raised the righteous living
are changed in a moment in a twinkling
of an eye and we all caught up to meet
Jesus in the air the wicked are
destroyed with the brightness of
Christ's coming the righteous go to
heaven for a thousand years I'll talk
more about that in just a minute at the
end of that thousand year period then
you reading Revelation chapter 21 the
new jerusalem descends from god out of
heaven and with it all the redeemed and
at that point jesus sets his feet on the
Mount of Olives and it opens up or forms
a great valley and the New Jerusalem
comes to rest in that valley then the
wicked are resurrected for what's
referred to in Revelation chapter 20 as
the great white throne judgment and at
the conclusion of that judgment then it
is that the wicked mount their attack
upon the New Jerusalem fire comes down
and devours them and the fire that
destroys the wicked purifies the earth
and then God creates a new earth wherein
dwells righteousness so that's sort of a
sequence of events so then my so then my
question is when the dead are raised the
wicked are raised and even you know when
they mount their attack on Jerusalem are
they going to receive new bodies - or
what are their bodies gonna look no they
don't receive immortal bodies you
probably similar - I mean it's as if
they've just been put together for that
final judgment the world's gonna be
quite different at the end of the
thousand years II can imagine everything
would have been destroyed they're not
gonna have time to go plan
harvest and you know eat the way we do
now so things are gonna be a little
different they'll be able to see angels
at that point there of course we'll see
the New Jerusalem they'll be able to
understand what's going on with a great
white throne judgment they won't have
immortal bodies but they will be
resurrected in some form for that final
judgment okay okay very good because I
guess and my mind I'm thinking gosh are
they gonna if they don't get new bodies
like we do or they gonna look like they
did when they died what if they died a
horrible you know tragic accident I mean
it's gonna be like you know I think
God's gonna put them together
sufficiently so that they can understand
what's going on and they have an
opportunity to participate in the
judgement meaning they have a not a
chance to ask the question well why am I
not saved and at the end of that
judgment according to the Bible it says
every knee bows and every tongue confess
that Jesus Christ is Lord even the devil
himself will acknowledge that God is
true in what he's done
it doesn't change their hearts because
no sooner do they say that and then they
mount this attack upon the New Jerusalem
but all the evidence will be presented
and it will be overwhelming even to the
wicked and they're gonna have to say no
God is true mm-hmm okay all right very
good well thank you so much for
everything that you do as well as pastor
bachelor we love you guys and just I
enjoy the show thank you well thank you
for your call we appreciate that I next
caller is Henry listening in Bronx New
York
Henry welcome to the program yes how are
you does the devil know the future he
knows a little bit of the future based
upon probably what he has learned from
the past in other words he's been around
for a long time he knows what the Bible
says he knows how the prophecies have
been fulfilled and I think he knows
what's coming that's why the devil the
Bible says the devil is going around
like a roaring lion seeking whom he may
devour
for he knows he has but a short time so
the devil knows his days are numbered
and he is trying to do everything he can
to bring as much misery and sorrow and
pain as he possibly can before he's
finally destroyed before that final
great judgement scene so he doesn't know
the future in the way that God would
know the future but he does know based
upon the prophecies of Scripture and
what he's learned from history he can at
least get a good idea of what's coming
you know I wonder know does he know
what's gonna happen the next minute no I
don't think so only God is omniscient
and not missing it means all-knowing and
the devil is not all-knowing
he can't read our minds that is a good
thing I mean he reads the actions that
he can tempt us but only God knows the
heart cuz I actually one more Christian
sure if a woman is married and she
marries her husband they're both
believers and he lands up backsliding
and never comes back with him well you
know that's a good question
when it comes to someone who are they
both married and in this case as you
said the husband is unfaithful the
commitment is still there to the spouse
and if all possible you want the
marriage to continue and sometimes by
the example of the wife or the example
of the husband they might be able to win
back that spouse who has turned away
from God if for some reason the spouse
who is no longer a Christian if they
choose to depart and do their own thing
then yes there is a point where the
believing spouse is freed from that
relationship but as long as possible I
think the believing spouse wants to be
the best example that he or she can be
and you know I've heard many stories and
I know of people who were faithful and
it took many years but finally their
spouse was one to Christ by their
example
so that's always something that one
wants to do well thank you for your call
Henry we appreciate it
next caller is Maria
listening from Fresno California Maria
welcome to the program hello pastor John
and pastor Doug thank you for your
program I have a neighbor who asked me a
question and I think I answered part
only
he asked hidden abortion when she was in
her early 20s and she asked if she's
going to see the baby at resurrection
time and I my answer was I know they're
going to be children in heaven but she
had a abortion on purpose she went to a
clinic and she had an abortion and she
was I don't remember if she was 6 weeks
or 26 weeks pregnant and that was my
answer yes what you are correct they are
gonna be babies in heaven and I think
there will be cases where perhaps a
young girl a teenager perhaps did have
an abortion but later on came to love
the Lord became a Christian committed
their life to Christ and perhaps they've
wondered all they've longed to see their
child you know if they trust in God and
they believe there's a possibility a
very real possibility that they get to
raise that child or that baby in heaven
I know that's probably true especially
for believing parents who have lost a
child prior to birth a miscarriage
there's a good chance that they will be
reunited with their child and get to
raise it in heaven so yes I believe that
is the case now having said that I don't
believe every aborted baby especially if
it's related to an unbelieving parent
will necessarily be in the resurrection
but for believing families believing
parents who love the Lord yes we have
the promise of the resurrection
so even if the baby wasn't born yes
absolutely according to the Bible you
know life begins when that heart starts
beating Jeremiah talks about how that
the Lord knew him in the womb and
formed him so yes yeah yeah we just have
a family right now that is going through
a difficult experience because they lost
their child or you know the baby I think
a few weeks into the pregnancy and it's
a difficult experience and they taking
comfort to know that yes they will see
that that baby in the resurrection even
though when she had the abortion she
wanted to have their abortion well you
know that's where we make mistakes and
you know we all make mistakes in
different ways but if we confess us and
Scotty's faithful to forgive us and
cleanse us and if she has committed a
life to Christ and she's a believer and
she longs to see that child there's
nothing stopping God from giving her
that child in the resurrection but again
that's God makes those decisions okay
I will I will definitely tell her yeah
absolutely
thank you so much thanks for your call
next caller is Charles listening in
Jordan Georgia Charles welcome to the
program yes
can you hear me yes I can hear you oh
great I just have a question about the
experience of being born again and when
I listen to preachers preach they're
always about theology about it you know
theological points but I listened to the
testimony and she's so described what
happened to her in her soul is there any
kind of universal spiritual experience
of the soul where you have evidence as
you know like skies bluer and the best
greener intense joy freedom you know
that's the thing she described okay can
you explain that where if someone says
have you been born again you can say yes
I have because this is what happened in
my soul
no I haven't because I have an
experience well even though I several
things sabri with all the truth yes
sometimes a person's conversion could be
very dramatic and you know they do have
a powerful testimony of how their lives
changed and they had this overwhelming
sense of peace knowing that they're
forgiven and it does occur and it's a
you know it's a powerful
but for many others they might come to
God in prayer especially those that
maybe grew up in a Christian home and
you know they commit their life to Jesus
they confess their sins
they might not have that same
overwhelming experience that somebody
else might have but it doesn't mean that
they're not converted or they not born
again the new birth experience comes in
the form of a seed not a full grown
plant let me explain when you take a
seed and you put it in the soil and you
cover it up you might not see anything
dramatic changing in that seed
immediately but given enough time the
seed germinates it begins to grow and it
becomes a full-grown tree that produces
fruit so it is with the Christian when
you receive Jesus as your personal
Savior the Holy Spirit places that new
heart within you you might not be able
to sense anything different at the
moment but you take God at His Word you
believe a promise given in Scripture and
as you keep trusting in him that new
life begins to grow and then you begin
to demonstrate the fruit of the Spirit
in your life so I wouldn't put any you
know you don't have to have some sort of
a wonderful emotional experience in
order to take God at His Word but we can
have faith to say Lord I believe what
you say I'm not gonna wait to feel a
certain way but I'm gonna simply take
you at your word and God wanted that
what about you know like joy you have a
joy of salvation their Bible talks about
that shouldn't there be an experience of
joy absolutely there is there is a peace
that passes all understanding that the
Bible speaks about but having said that
it doesn't mean a Christian doesn't face
discouraging circumstances I mean look
look at David in some of the Psalms he
was converted but he went through all
kinds of difficulties where you know he
struggled you have job who faced all
kinds of trials and difficulties and
disappointing experiences
faith is still claiming God's promise
even if we don't feel like it that's
holding onto his word so yes the
Christian does have peace the Christian
does have joy but it doesn't mean that
they don't have temptations or
discouragement or difficult
circumstances
despite those things we want to hold on
a belief well what if you believe the
truth and and even know that you're very
well but you've never really experienced
joy and your whole Christian experience
would you question whether you're a
Christian you know if you never
experienced joy or even more so peace a
peace that passes understanding one
needs to do is spend a little more time
in prayer and by faith claim the
promises of God trust God just simply
take him at his word and God will give
you the peace that does give you
strength and courage to face different
trials in life so I want to encourage
you to do that it's an important thing
we don't want to simply live by our
feelings but as a Christian there is a
piece that we have that gives us
confidence that God is true but take him
at his word hold on team by faith it's
an important thing for us to do thank
you for your call Charles we're gonna
try and get a few more calls in before
we run out of time our next caller that
we have is Boonton from alabama i
believe it's boone welcome to the
program hi welcome and your question yes
my question is i read in revelation i
studying and i want to know that it's
dog don't go to heaven do dogs go to
heaven all right well we know they are
going to be animals in heaven the Bible
speaks of the lion and the lamb and
they'll probably be all kinds of animals
all they exactly the same animal that we
have here on the earth in other words is
our pet dog or cat going to be in heaven
well God could probably create a dog or
a cat that's very much like the ones we
have here but with reference to the
gospel Jesus died for us
he didn't die for the dogs and the cats
he died to save mankind those created in
his image then the second question is
okay that the New Jerusalem yes I love
garden I love a plan when my plane
diving being at am calm I feel sad for
them I tell them I said one day we could
we all go to heaven
I looked at you and me and and I wonder
you know we have a garden and new
Jerusalem do we plan yes we will matter
of fact the Bible tells us that we will
plant vineyards and eat the fruit of it
have fig trees and thinks about yes the
the new earth
it describes these things what is my
dream I want to do buy a car to help me
to get there absolutely I did yellow my
heart want to obey but you have to help
me I talked to God I believe me I
believe it all my heart I believe God
surreal
absolutely my life all my life I come
from Thailand
I don't know that I come to learn about
God when I come to United States
you know we doing light we do have a
study guide that I think you'd really
enjoy and we'll send it to you for free
if you just give us a call and ask for
it it's all about heaven actually gives
you the scriptures about what people are
gonna do in heaven and to get that just
call our resource phone number it's
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven I'm gonna tell you the number
again 808 three five six seven four
seven ask for the study guide about
heaven it's called a colossal city in
space just ask for the study guide about
heaven I'll be happy to send that to you
there's just got some wonderful promises
there in the Word of God thank you for
your call a next caller is Sunil from
Redlands California
Sunil welcome to the program yep yes I
am here yes thanks for your call we have
just a few minutes left
okay no problem and your question my
course my question when Moses was in the
wilderness with the Israel people yes
and there was built the sensory same
kind of sensory in heaven and what Jesus
is doing in the heaven now okay good
question yes there is a sanctuary in
heaven and it was told when Moses built
the sanctuary he was to build it
according to the pattern that was shown
him so the earthly sanctuary was a
miniature of the heavenly sanctuary
Jesus is currently our high priest in
the heavenly sanctuary if you want to
read about that the whole book of
Hebrews in the New Testament is all
about the high priestly ministry of
Jesus in the heavenly sanctuary what
specifically is he doing for us he is
interceding on our behalf in other words
when we confess our sins he appears as
our advocate and he atones his sacrifice
covers our sins just like the priests in
the Old Testament we take the blood of
animals and and sprinkle it there on the
veil of the sanctuary so Jesus is
ministering the merits of his sacrifice
there are actually three phases to the
Ministry of Jesus when Jesus came to the
earth he came as our sacrifice he was
the Lamb of God that takes away the sins
of the world now Jesus is ministering in
heaven as our high priest but soon his
high priestly ministry will finish and
Jesus will come back as king of kings
and Lord of lords
so there's three distinct phases of
Christ's ministry he's both our
sacrifice he's also our priest and then
he comes back not as a priest but as
king king of kings and Lord of lords
thank you sir laughter Shirdi Aransas
absolutely well thank you for your call
you know we do have a study guide
that'll tell you more about the
sanctuary and the work that Jesus is
doing as a high priest it's called God
built the plans and it's all about the
sanctuary you can just ask for that and
we'll be happy to send that to you that
God built the plans it's about the
heavenly sanctuary and I think you'd
find that very interesting the number to
call is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven that is the
resource phone number again the number
is 883 five six seven four seven you can
ask for any of the resources that we
mentioned on the program tonight and
we'll be happy to send it to anybody who
calls and asks well friends as you can
hear we have the music playing in the
background that means we are running out
of time I want to thank you for all of
the calls this evening and if we didn't
get to your call tonight don't give up
give us a call next time and we'll try
and take your Bible question on the air
until then I want to encourage you to
take a look at amazing facts website
just amazing facts calm
more information till next time thank
you for listening to today's broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
can't get enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vor G are you wondering what
lies ahead in human history or what
piece of world events are harbingers of
the end are you ready for the coming
crisis landmarks of prophecy offers
clearer answers to your most pressing
questions presented by pastor Doug
Batchelor landmarks of prophecy is a
contemporary video Bible study adventure
designed for today's audiences
presenting the landmark themes of the
Bible and a bright and compelling way
helping you understand the Bible better
and giving you knowledge to face the
future with confidence landmarks of
prophecy contains over 30 hours of
exciting video presentations on six DVDs
plus bonus question and answer sessions
giving you keen insight into what lies
next in human history if you'd like
practical tools to help you thrive and
survive in the here and now get
landmarks of prophecy start your epic
Bible study adventure with landmarks of
prophecy today by calling
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our website at WWF ag0
RG and sign up for our free Bible study
course and make sure to check out our
online bookstore at AF bookstore com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books DVDs and more to help you get the
most out of God's Word to take advantage
of the offers you've heard on this
broadcast call us at
[Music]